in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ted is
with us hi Ted how are you doing great
Dave welcome where are you from
we're from Northeast Denver Northeast
Denver okay very cool sounds like almost
out the airport direction correct yeah
very cool all right and who is this with
you it's my son Parker and my daughter
Talia and their how old I tell you I'm
15 and my brother's 13 all right very
cool and you guys are here to do a
family debt free scream yes sir
absolutely
I love it so how much have you paid off
Ted it's uh just shy of a hundred and
sixteen thousand way to go man how long
did that take you took three years and
seven months all right making what kind
of income range during that time now I
started around 110 and finished up this
last year around 200 good for you what
do you do for a living sir
an IT technology consultant all right
very good
obviously doing well at it
congratulations Thanks very cool so what
happened three years and seven months
ago they lit you on fire like this I had
a sit-down with my accountant and
realized they owed quite a bit more
money than I thought
pretty much just did a poor job managing
my my hole in the tax side of my
business and wasn't really ready for the
outcome when the whole true up came down
and so a lot of this was taxes
um actually wasn't huge but it was
enough to scare the heck out of me yeah
you don't want the KGB I mean the IRS
after you you know exactly yeah so what
was the 116 what was it owed on a lot of
different things that heard people say
on the show quite a few times when they
do their screams that they didn't find
an item that they didn't know on I kind
of feel the same way there was a
business loan there was a car to pay off
much was the car car was about 6,000 so
not not too bad on that too bad
and then the taxes was about ten
we had orthodontics beautiful teeth
uh-huh
nice smiles and I smiled
about a 1,400 and I did the dreaded
timeshare which I regret today that was
about 5400 mm-hm
and so the vast majority was the
business loan the vast majority of the
biggest debt that I paid off just
recently was the second mortgage on the
home oh okay all right and that was
about 63,000 gotcha okay there's a big
one in there because I was hearing all
those little ones okay yeah cool very
cool so you sit down all your accountant
the taxes are due and you're like okay
I'm gonna have to be a grown-up and look
at that I can't just look at the
earnings side I have to look at the
outgo side too I got to clean this up
then what did you do
you know I got scared I actually I had
heard about FPU from my sister about ten
years ago
and so the seed had been planted and my
sister kind of laid laid the path for
for my siblings my brothers and my other
sisters but I never really jumped on the
bandwagon and went to church one day and
one of the guys that I befriended over
the last few years
invited me to to come to FPU a financial
peace with with him and his wife and so
I finally decided yeah it just sounds
great I've been meaning to do this for a
while now and had this bad meeting at
the accountants when I was the time I
did I need to get my stuff together now
so I went and had an interesting
reaction that I don't hear from a lot of
people on the video channel but after
the third week at FPU I was angry I
don't know if you get that reaction for
many people it's probably my crazy
driven personality I'm a Heidi so in the
disc profile but I just remember being
angry for about two weeks because I was
looking for that person to blame and
that person of course is the the man in
the mirror yeah and you know as soon as
I realized it was it was my fault
what I had led myself up to you know I
finally started getting a little more
serious you know I went through that I
don't always hear a lot of people bring
it up like you said there but when we
went broke that was what I that's what
happened to me
I woke up and I was I kind of went
through the traditional stages of grief
you know denial and then anger is next
and I and acceptance you know and so
that was kind of what I did and that's
when I the acceptance part was when I
looked in the mirror like you said and I
said okay you're the problem but you're
also the solution get off your butt son
and get this moving and that's exactly
what you did yep Wow
very cool very cool well that's because
that's it's a great emotion if it's
challenged in a positive way or
channeled in a positive way that is so
very cool so what part did Talia and
Parker play in this process well we have
just been here this whole time
we live with him half the time and with
mom half the time and it was a real
shock at first because we were kind of
like what is dad doing
he's joy what what is happening why are
we suddenly not going out to eat why are
we suddenly and he kind of explained to
us and this happened when I was about 12
so it took a little getting used to and
I think the hardest moment would have
been last summer when I loved Christian
music and my two of my absolute favorite
artists Kari Jobe and rend collective
had this huge concert at Red Rocks and I
told him like a month in advance and at
this at this point in time I knew how
the budget system worked I knew that we
like we had to do this the beginning of
the month so I told him a month in
advance you know I told him I really
want to go to this and we need to go to
this and I just remember him saying nope
we got to pay off the debt and I was
kind of like oh oh there's the bottom
yeah so now that you've seen even go
through all of this you're you're
obviously in a bright articulate young
lady what what have you seen change in
your dad just this drive in him this
it's beautiful to watch this
transformation that has happened and I'm
super duper proud of him for just
sticking to this and going through this
and it's just been wonderful to see wow
I can't get much better in here your
kids say that life's life's pretty good
Ted well done sir well done that's
awesome
very cool so Ted when people hear
that a single dad has paid off 116
thousand dollars in debt and they say
how did you do that what do you tell
them the secrets to getting out of debt
are you know I think a lot of it is it
has to do with the system that you and
your teams created I think you know this
the video channel everybody that's in
here right now I'm sure has has taken a
look at the video channel I'm sure
everyone's heard you on the radio I mean
if you're single for sure and I say this
to all the single guys and gals that are
you know going through this plan today
you just have to tie into the system you
have to tie into the radio listen to the
radio does it pick a couple days that
you can get a you know half an hour in
and just be devout about listening to it
every single day if you can becomes your
support system is that what you're
saying totally oh yeah yeah I know the
debt-free screams are highly viewed on
YouTube people watch them over and over
and over again for constant updates and
there was Rober is get them emailed to
them it makes it real easy to stay
caught up on them and that kind of thing
you know
and that's the only explanation for that
is it consistently lifts it up it's it's
a form of community it really is that
does that so that's cool that's cool so
what did you do tactically that caused
you to be able to get out of debt what
things do you blame that on that you did
you know I the journey has been you know
obviously three years and seven months
it's a it seems like a lot longer but um
you know it started David it definitely
started as a spiritual journey I think
after the divorce I ended up sort of
plugging back into to my relationship
with Christ and going back to church on
a regular basis and really starting to
incorporate that in with my kids as well
that was really important to me it's
obviously playing paying huge dividends
well congratulations you guys very very
well done all right Ted Talia Parker
from Denver Colorado
a hundred and sixteen thousand dollars
paid off three years and
seven months making 110 up to 200 count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream 3 2 yeah
that's how it's done right there hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
and say you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind